if you recall one of the first ways that
we understood simple harmonic motion
right was by three equations three
equations that we thought about we
developed we applied calculus to it
right
we call them the time equations why did
we call them the time equations
because they had time in them they were
functions of time
right so let's just rehearse what they
were as an example if we started with a
sine
and t
you differentiate once right
everything's still in terms of time
so you get x dot or alternatively you
get v for velocity
okay and what do we get in this case
just
a and cos right
is this ringing balance yes we
differentiated one more time
to get to x double dot to acceleration
and then we noticed when you do chain
rule and you make that
cause flip back to a negative sign right
you get this
now we said look we don't need to think
about time anymore once we have
this statement okay because we know what
all of this is
in terms of x and that's where this
important differential equation
stuck out from okay this guy here right
now we're going to push on this a little
further the idea of understanding
motion and how a particle an object is
behaving
and moving in terms of displacement
that's why this heading is
functions of displacement okay now just
a bit of a preface
what we're going to do is not just going
to apply the simple harmonic version see
this equation here
right this equation is only true for
simple harmonic motion okay
but some of the things that we will look
at will be general principles that apply
because x velocity and acceleration
displacement velocity acceleration are
related to each other by calculus so i
want you to watch out sometimes i'll say
to you
look at this have a look at the maths of
how we got this this applies to all
motion not just simple harmonic
whereas other parts of it you look at
the features and how we arrive to those
conclusions and prove those results and
you say look
this this came from this so it only
applies to simple harmonic one of the
things that i've seen by teaching
extension a few times is just how easy
it is to confuse those
and people use simple harmonic equations
uh
uh differential equations where it's not
simple harmonic motion and
vice versa okay so just as a heads up be
wary of that
so we have acceleration as a function of
displacement
already we know how to do that okay the
next sort of logical step
is to think about rather than
acceleration in terms of displacement
the other quantity that we don't know
about which is velocity
okay now um remember i said to you some
things here are going to be applicable
to wider varieties of motion not just
simple harmonic okay
so the example that i'm going to give
you here to help you understand this is
not going to be simple hormone version
because then the maths of it
is easier to understand okay and then
we'll progress the simple harmonic a bit
later on
okay so i'm going to give you a
situation i'm going to pose a question
to you and then let's see what we can do
with it okay so
suppose we have a particle and its
motion is governed by
this equation okay and it starts at the
origin
wherever that is
okay now my question simply is can we
describe how this thing moves
describe the motion is the way the
nature c question
would say
okay so in order to describe this right
we want to know about the three things
displacement velocity and acceleration
but if you want to describe it it's very
hard to talk about it
without reference to how time is passing
right
so this equation velocity is a function
displacement
is timeless right it doesn't care about
when things are happening
it cares about where they're happening
so i need to do something to it
i need to introduce time into here
now uh just have a look at it for a
second
can you think just from what you know
about what velocity is
and what this equation looks like and
all of this stuff right can anyone offer
some suggestions for how i might
introduce time into this equation so
that i can then try and work out
what these are in terms of time any
takers
say a bit louder earlier okay
i was a bit sneaky wasn't i i said that
this has no time in it timeless equation
but it's not really a timeless equation
is it because what's v what's it short
for
what is velocity it's the change in
displacement
over time right it's really a derivative
okay so i could say i'm going to go pick
something
going around that space i can say that
the x of t
is e or minus x okay because because
that's what
velocity is okay so time really is in
here
now that's good i've got time in there
but what i really want
is expressions equations for
displacement velocity and acceleration
that are
functions of time okay and this is not a
function of time it's still a function
of x
so what can i do to this i can
just flip this over right the reason why
flipping over is a good idea
what's going to happen on the left-hand
side dt or dx
what's going to happen with the
right-hand side it's just well that's
just e to the x isn't it right
because that's one over e to the x so
i'll take the reciprocal the reason why
this is a good way to go is because now
i can integrate right i can integrate i
can get an expression
for t okay so uh more broadly speaking
if i said this
just kick that guy over there okay i can
now integrate both sides this is a bit
weird right
um usually we are used to saying oh
integrate both sides with respect to
this or that or the other okay but the
weird thing about this equation
is that what you're integrating with
respect to has already been supplied
and they're different but that's okay
watch
bless you okay i can do this
right uh really that's the integral of
one
isn't it okay and this is with respect
to time
so what am i going to get here t
integral of e to the x it's just e to
the x
now this is an indefinite integral right
so i really should have some constants
flying around
however being that you'll get a constant
from here and a constant from here
the difference between two constants is
still a constant so i don't really need
two constants do i
i can get away with just one so i'll
just stick him over here
okay great now this is good this is
progress
it's still not a function of ex of
displacement or velocity or acceleration
yet though
is it so what can i do any suggestions
now don't forget um i did give you very
little information
a scant amount of information for this
question right
but we've only accounted for this
equation so far haven't we
we took this guy and then we started
working with him right away
okay so what can i do with this what
does that tell you
when t equals 0 x equals 0 right so i
have an initial condition
right i can put that in and i can
evaluate what this constant is
be careful what am i going to get here
i'm going to get 0 equals
e to the power of 0 plus c
and it's so it's so common when you say
ah look initial contin
condition is 0 so the constant is 0
right of course
not of course what's the constant it's
negative one when that one moves over
the other side
right classic beginner's error watch out
so i mean it like as a marker
right i'm going through and there are
kinds of mistakes which
um yeah they they happen a lot and it
it's very revealing about the kind of
understanding someone has
if someone gets to here right here says
when t equals zero
x equals zero therefore c equals zero
which i see
lots right far more than i want to that
tells me
you don't really know what's going on
like you're so used to taking the
shortcut
right and you're always saying class nah
it's okay i know the proper way to do it
i'll do the working in the exam
and then you don't so anyway there you
go there's my constant
t equals e to the x minus 1.
that's good now i can get an equation
for x can i
what should i do
i should move that one out of the way
first so i'm going to get this
is t plus 1 and of course what i'm
really after is x as the subject so take
logs on both sides no problem
okay now once we've gotten to here
that's all the hard work really that's
all the hard conceptual work because
we're used to these kinds of situations
i if i've got a displacement equation
the rest of it just falls out
and then i can describe the motion from
there okay so let's just quickly do it
x dot of course is going to be
1 over x equals 1 good there's my
velocity
okay and acceleration this is t plus 1
to the power of negative 1
isn't it so when you do chain rule it's
going to become
negative one over t plus one squared
isn't it that's
t plus one to the negative two cool
there you go
there's displacement velocity
acceleration and now all that's left is
to turn it into words
okay